so much fun so with the big game comes
big drinks and here to tell us more is
Robert parak with trustworthy Brewing
which is located in the Grand Canal
shops at the Venetian welcome to the
show thank you thank you for having us
you guys were the only Craft brewery on
Las Vegas Boulevard correct we are
congratulations on that thank you thank
you you guys are doing something very
special for the big game you're rolling
out two new beers tell me about the
beers you have absolutely so we Brew two
new beers specifically for the game we
have a Belgian style Whit beer uh we
have our version of A Nevada Style Pale
Ale
um really really unique beers that are
going to go great uh in quantity for the
game yeah of course you want a drink in
a quantity you're watching the big game
you need to have some beers was there a
thought behind the beers like an AFC
beard an NFC beer what was your thought
process uh we thought one will do like a
traditional kind of West Coast style
paleo and then the other we wanted to go
the opposite way with the Hops and go
something a little bit sweeter a little
bit softer and so we've wanted to kind
of have that dichotomy of the two beers
and we'll see which one sells the best
on the big game and that will be the
winner yes yeah absolutely food too this
spread of food here talk about some of
the food that you guys have for the big
game absolutely our executive chef Jose
Carrera did a great job in kind of uh
revamping our food menu we wanted stuff
that was familiar that tasted great and
that would go great obviously
um in quantity with beer for the game
this is I'm looking at everything finger
foods this is the stuff you want to be
sitting there watching the game with the
chicken fingers you got a big pretzel
here what are some of this stuff down
here corn dogs absolutely so we have all
beef corn dogs we have our spicy buffalo
wings we do uh jumbo Bavarian style
pretzels that is a big pretzel right
there absolutely definitely and it goes
great with the cheese sauce uh deviled
eggs which are you know picnic food but
it goes great with football and beer as
well our trustworthy Burger but last but
not least we have uh brisket nachos and
so we slow smoke the brisket overnight
uh chop it and then obviously everything
you think I'm gonna stop it right there
you slow roast that brisket right
absolutely shave it off on top of these
nachos that's what you want to be eating
when you're rooting on your team enjoy
the big game exactly TVs that's I mean
all all this stuff is perfect but you
need a place to watch the game talk
about the TVs in the setup we just
finished at 250 000 AV upgrade we put in
130 square foot LED video wall we put
TVs on every piece of the wall we can
figure so that if you're sitting at the
bar if you're sitting in the dining room
you get an amazing view of the game
you're gonna feel like you're actually
at the game absolutely with the amount
of TV you have the amount of beers this
is awesome uh reservations recommended
or just absolutely no definitely
reservations are recommended uh we're
doing a package that includes unlimited
draft beer unlimited open Premium Bar
from noon until the game ends and
reservations can be made at our website
at
www.trustworthybrewingco.com okay final
question they're gonna wrap it up who's
gonna win ah it's gonna be tough but I
think the Eagles are going to pull it
out oh you heard it from Robert thank
you so much for joining us we appreciate
it thank you Jillian we'll send it